[Applause]
a show of descent in the heart of
political decision-making in baghdad
[Applause]
protesters taking over the speaker's
plinth and mp's benches
their supporters of the influential shia
cleric
he says he does not want muhammad
al-sudani to be the next prime minister
and his supporters are likely attempting
to enforce this
this is only from baghdad he didn't
bring his supporters from other
provinces
stormed the green zone the parliament
they're in good numbers it seems to me
that there is a plan of escalating this
protesting movement so to speak
he basically wants to dislodge the
the candidate for the premiership
and this is how they got through the
heavily fortified so-called green zone
undeterred by water cannon protesters
ripped through the cement blast walls
surrounding a 10 kilometer stretch of
the city
dozens pass with apparent ease forcing
their way down the main thoroughfare
towards parliament
they remained there until sada
instructed them to withdraw
in a tweet he described it as a
revolution of reform and rejection of
corruption saying the message had been
delivered and the protesters have
terrified the corrupt in power
sadda is one of the most popular
politicians in iraq his party was the
biggest winner in october's election but
he failed to form a majority coalition
last month more than 70 mps allied with
the shia cleric resigned from parliament
calling it corrupt
now the pro-iran coordination framework
is nominating sudani as prime minister
for now this is a victory for sardis and
a threat to political decision makers
analysts say protesters are likely to
maintain the pressure from the streets
law bowden manly al jazeera